spaghetti sauce ah spaghetti sauce all
the white matter wife ah bread fetch
them on lunchy spicy vegetarian not too
spicy sweetie just so happens I'm in a
meeting here with the real live Italian
mama has a great recipe wants to give it
to his name's weed oh why don't you say
hello to my daughter hello i am a Guido
wipe out a generation of people you can
burn their homes to the ground and
somehow they'll still come back but if
you destroy their achievements in the
history and it's like they never existed
just ash floating that's what Hitler
wants and it's the one thing we simply
can't allow bedtimes no Crowley faces no
bushy mustaches and no negativity of any
kind you just said the word no like a
thousand times and there's also no
consistency I hate this play any idea is
a good idea except the not happy once
those you push down deep inside where
you'll never ever ever is the work of
demons
it has begun
he undermines our faith
here includes adulteress pita
Tandy a cheek you pay the price for this
like your friend John the Baptist I
didn't do anything with me no Marshall
is someone gonna tell us what the hell
is going on need your help hey people
are scared we have a right to know why
you searched us what is plain almost
went down hey Marshall you and I are
gonna have a conversation don't you walk
away from know dr. cockpit now you learn
that guy in a cockbag here's what's
gonna happen you're gonna go back to
your seat you're gonna sit down and
you're gonna shut up what come on cop to
another you know